jusqu'à ce matin devant le château le
smartphone servait plutôt as la selphy
photo de groupe ou du monument
aujourd'hui avec vous seul le portable
se transforme en encyclopédie ludique
pratique et géolocalisés et dès que
j'avais passé à côté des points
d'intérêt le système à m'envoyer une
notification pour dire ici on peut vous
raconter des choses sur la faune la
flore les paysages
l'utilisateur choisit ses points
d'intérêts il y en a 21 sur les mille
hectares de parc
il peut choisir la distance la
difficulté le moyen de transport le
temps de parcours le logiciel s'occupe
du reste
ça m'a l'air bien sympathique et ça
permet peut-être de se balader de
manière indépendante et puis en prenant
son temps tout en découvrant des choses
pour aller jusqu'au pont de la
canardière
ces 35 minutes de marche et des zones
arrivant en plus des signes et d'une vue
très bucolique sur le château les
informations arrivent aussitôt sur la
tablette
qu'est ce qu'une canardière où il
explique évidemment aux visiteurs et on
essaie aussi de leur montrer ce qu'elles
étaient au faîte de son aménagement à
l'époque de louis xiv de cumont anciens
animations permettent de comprendre
d'apprendre de découvrir des lieux
insolites comme le grand fossé 10 mètres
de profondeur creusé sans doute à la
construction du château pour assécher
les marais ils courent tous tout au sud
il contourne le château et il revient
ensuite vers vers la rivière c'est un
élément extraordinaire du parc de
chambord à découvrir grâce notamment à
cette application
cette application est l'aboutissement du
programme intelligence des patrimoines
piloté par l'université de tours
il réunit des scientifiques de toutes
spécialités avec comme sujet commun
chambord certaines équipes étudié par
exemple la dissémination des graines
dans les poils de sanglier d'autres
étudient l'image de chambord à travers
les siècles d'autres étudié
l'archéologie et donc il fallait ensuite
trouvé le moyen de valoriser le résultat
de toutes les recherches et l'idée est
venue de créer une application au
service du public où l'on donnerait
accès à des contenus de façon un peu
plus vulgarisée mais en tout cas ce sont
des contenus scientifiques
la boussole est un moyen de ne pas
perdre le nord à chambord mais surtout
de faire parler des paysages et les
pierres de l'histoire de france